Générique
...
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table",
où on parle cuisine,
alimentation, agriculture,
écologie et un peu politique.
Et nous recevons
Valérie Masson-Delmotte.
-Bonjour.
-Et avec moi,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour à vous.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes
paléoclimatologue, c'est-à-dire
que vous étudiez les climats passés
et leurs variations, intéressant
au moment de la COP28
à Dubaï, qui climatise
ses terrasses.
Vous êtes directrice
de recherches
au Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et vous avez été
coprésidente d'un groupe du GIEC
jusqu'en juillet dernier,
date à laquelle
le bureau a été renouvelé.
En 2022, vous avez été classée
parmi les 100 personnalités
les plus influentes
du monde par le magazine Time.
Promis, Jean-Pierre vient à vélo,
et moi, je prends le RER.
Pas de souci là-dessus.
Vous êtes celle
que le président
et tout le gouvernement
consultent après la canicule
de 2022.
Une formation expresse de 30 minutes
et des entretiens bilatéraux
avec les ministres
pour leur dire que la France
doit doubler son rythme
de baisse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
pour respecter l'accord de Paris.
Après avoir dit ça,
il faut un menu exemplaire.
-Oui, un vrai menu végétarien,
avec des légumes de saison,
du chou romanesco, butternut,
purée de pois chiches,
et en dessert,
une salade de fruits.
-Dans Le dessous des plats :
l'élevage fortement émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre.
Faut-il se passer de la viande ?
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat :
la France au régime sec.
Des villages dans le sud frappés
par la sécheresse
sont approvisionnés en eau
par camions-citernes.
-Allez,
on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
je voulais vous dire
que j'ai fait un cauchemar,
j'ai rêvé qu'avec Brigitte,
on recevait en pleine COP28
l'ex copatronne du GIEC,
"Goinfres, irréductibles,
"éternels et carbonés",
un groupuscule
d'ultras non pas identitaires
mais culinaires.
Les réseaux sociaux
étaient déchaînés
contre ces apôtres de la bouffe
du monde d'hier
qui ont réclamé ici
des côtes de boeuf gonflées
aux hormones,
des poulets
gavés aux protéines
élevés en batteries chinoises.
Je me suis réveillé
en sursaut quand des monceaux
de fraises
méga carbonées du Chili
étaient servis.
En transe,
j'ai réalisé
que GIEC signifiait "Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental
"sur l'évolution du climat".
Ouf
pour notre image,
mais sur la table, oups :
on est passés de l'orgie
alimentaire hérétique
au repas de la cantoche
subventionné
par une mairie écolo.
Des légumes de saison,
choux romanesco
et purée de pois chiches.
Cette présentation
est volontairement
caricaturale pour illustrer
la bataille
radicalisée autour
de notre assiette demain.
Ce plat-là,
c'est la recette
pour bien vieillir ?
-En fait, c'est un plat,
je pense,
qui est bien équilibré,
avec de tout, des fibres,
des légumineuses,
des protéines végétales,
et ça fait partie des choses
qui permettent de vivre
longtemps en bonne santé,
et de réduire l'empreinte carbone.
Ca fait partie des leviers d'actions
importants pour agir en termes
de santé publique,
mais aussi à avoir
un système alimentaire
plus durable.
C'est un enjeu majeur.
Dans le monde,
le système alimentaire,
c'est 30 %
des émissions de gaz.
C'est pas seulement
des enjeux climat :
800 millions de personnes
souffrent de malnutrition
et de faim, deux milliards
de personnes qui souffrent
de surpoids et d'obésité.
On touche
à des enjeux majeurs
pour la soutenabilité.
-Alors
c'est un menu politiquement correct
que vous nous proposez.
Vous mangez toujours comme ça ?
-Je suis devenue végétarienne
il y a quelques années.
J'espère surtout que c'est bon.
Parce qu'en fait,
cuisiner essentiellement
à base de plantes, c'est un défi,
ça demande d'arriver à sublimer
le goût des légumes,
des légumineuses, par exemple.
C'est un défi plus grand
pour beaucoup de cuisiniers.
Donc on voit des choses
intéressantes.
-Vous avez choisi
d'être végétarienne.
Qu'est-ce qui a été le déclic ?
Le climat, j'imagine.
Le dérèglement climatique ?
L'empreinte carbone ?
Ou il y avait
cette envie de mieux manger,
d'être en bonne santé ?
-Il y a un peu de tout.
Dans ma vie personnelle,
j'essaie de me mettre
plus en cohérence,
dans ma vie professionnelle aussi,
entre la manière dont on vit
et les enjeux d'arriver à alléger
notre empreinte environnementale.
Donc dans ma démarche familiale,
ça a fait partie des choix,
à un moment donné,
qui sont devenus une pratique
au quotidien.
-Toute la famille s'y est mise ?
-Non, on a tout un spectre de choix.
Du coup, on apprend à cuisinier
un peu à la carte.
Ceux qui veulent manger
de la viande,
de la charcuterie,
le font, ceux qui n'en veulent pas
ont un autre choix.
-Il y a de la tolérance ?
-Oui, c'est de la convivialité
et de la liberté.
-Vous aviez réclamé
des légumes de saison.
Là, il y a du chou romanesco.
-C'est parfait.
-Butternut, et des légumineuses,
lentilles
et pois chiches. D'habitude, on fait
plutôt lentilles ou pois chiches ?
-Ca ressemble
à la manière dont on se nourrit
depuis des milliers d'années,
notamment en Méditerranée,
où les légumineuses font partie
des plats habituels.
A l'époque
de mon arrière-grand-mère,
la viande était un luxe.
On n'en mangeait pas tous les jours.
C'est revenir à du bon sens
où on cherche un équilibre,
et que ce soit bon et nutritif.
-En Méditerranée,
on mange du poisson aussi.
Il y a pas que des menus
végétariens.
-Non, l'idée, c'est pas d'imposer
mais de s'interroger
sur trouver un juste équilibre
entre ce qu'on aime manger,
les enjeux de santé,
de préservations des revenus
des agriculteurs,
de la production agricole.
Et en France, on fait aussi
des lentilles et des pois chiches.
-C'est une vraie privation
pour vous, ou ça l'a été,
de se priver de viande,
ou vous n'aimiez pas tellement ça ?
-Ca a été
une évolution régulière.
Je vois pas du tout ça
comme une privation.
C'est penser autrement
la façon de se nourrir,
se faire plaisir en mangeant.
Moi, j'aime bien manger.
Mais autrement.
C'est un chouette défi, je trouve.
-On goûte ensemble.
-Vous parliez de la Méditerranée.
On parle du régime crétois
pour vieillir longtemps,
un régime très sain
avec du poisson, de l'huile.
Celui-ci est encore plus sain ?
-Je peux pas évaluer,
parce que c'est pas un plat,
mais c'est le fait de diversifier
son alimentation
à l'échelle de la semaine,
du mois.
En réalité, beaucoup de gens
qui sont soucieux des deux,
de l'empreinte environnementale,
privilégier la production agricole
de proximité française,
- il y a des enjeux majeurs
sur les revenus
des agriculteurs -
et manger sain,
qui font le choix, pas systématique,
mais de remplacer
à un moment donné un repas
par une offre végétale.
La cantine où je vais manger
le midi, il y a toujours
une offre alternative,
et l'intendant, en fait,
me disait que c'est maintenant
à peu près 30 % des plats
qui sont choisis comme ça.
-Mais c'est bon
ou c'est quelques légumes
sur l'assiette ?
-Je goûte.
-C'est Chez Françoise
qui a cuisiné,
donc c'est forcément bon.
-Ca manque un peu de sel,
mais c'est pas bon pour la santé.
Et les pois chiches,
je voulais en parler,
ils sont en purée.
-C'est plutôt
du houmous,
qu'on retrouve dans les pays
du Moyen-Orient, du Proche-Orient.
Trois choses à savoir
sur le pois chiche.
-C'est un aliment
santé, riche en fibres,
en minéraux et en vitamines B.
Il est très protéiné, pauvre
en matières grasses et rassasiant,
donc très utile
dans un régime végétarien.
On le trouve toute l'année,
cuit en bocal et en conserve.
Dans ces cas, il suffit
de le faire réchauffer.
S'il est sec, il faut le faire
tremper tout une nuit
ou une heure dans une eau
bouillonnante.
Ensuite, il faut bien rincer
pour enlever la peau autour
avant de lancer la vraie cuisson
qui peut durer encore
une heure et demie.
Si vous aimez les bons pois chiches
de nos campagnes, secs,
il faut y penser à l'avance.
Il se mange froid, en salade,
avec des oignons, du cumin,
il est mixé en purée,
c'est le houmous,
mais aussi chaud,
dans un curry indien,
avec du lait de coco,
et dans un couscous
ou même avec des pâtes.
Ca paraît un peu bizarre,
mais c'est très bon.
C'est de Calabre.
-C'est peut-être
un peu plus lourd.
-Oui,
moitié de pâtes et un peu
de pois chiches,
mais protéines et pâtes,
c'est la "cucina povera".
-Ca vous plaît ?
-C'est très bon,
et il y a une herbe,
qui est parfumée
et très bonne.
Il y a une recette moins légère.
On les met sur une plaque
avec de l'huile d'olive,
du paprika ou une épice,
ça fait comme des chips.
Et le houmous en apéritif
avec des légumes crus,
c'est agréable.
-Et la farine de pois chiches,
avec les panisses.
-Oui, une tradition
méditerranéenne de Nice.
-Vous nous disiez que c'est pas
toujours facile de bien cuisiner,
sans protéine végétale...
Animale, pardon.
Ca veut dire
qu'il faut des sauces,
des herbes, il faut agrémenter
ces légumes ?
-Relever le goût du légume,
le mettre en valeur
pour pas que ce soit fade.
-Pas forcément avec du sel,
comme le disait Jean-Pierre ?
-Non mais ce qui est joli aussi,
c'est ce qu'on voit là,
dans la culture
végétarienne en Inde
ou en Amérique du Sud,
c'est jouer sur les couleurs,
pour que ce soit appétissant.
Là, il y en a cinq ou six,
c'est très joli.
-J'aurais bien mis
un peu d'huile d'olive,
mais l'indice calorique
est plus fort.
Ca aurait un peu...
-C'est pas mauvais,
l'huile d'olive.
-C'est gras, quand même.
C'est meilleur
que l'huile d'arachide.
-Il y a un enjeu parce qu'avec
la chaleur extrême
de cette année en Méditerranée,
Espagne, Grèce, etc.,
la production a chuté
et le coût de l'huile d'olive
a fortement augmenté.
C'est un enjeu parce que
les oliviers
sont des arbres
à la croissance lente.
Et donc, dans les pays
qui sont plus secs, la distance
entre les arbres va être liée
à la quantité d'eau disponible,
et ça fait partie des enjeux
importants d'adaptation
pas évidente dans un climat
qui se réchauffe et qui s'assèche.
-J'étais en Espagne
il y a pas très longtemps.
Les Espagnols sont furieux
parce que dans les étals,
le prix de l'huile a doublé,
et ils savent pas comment cuisiner.
En Italie, il y a les maladies
dans les Pouilles,
où on a détruit des oliviers.
-Vous aimer
cuisiner ?
Qu'est-ce que vous faites
à la maison ?
-Des pois chiches.
-Non, en fait, j'ai pas
toujours le temps
de cuisiner,
donc c'est souvent
rapide dans la semaine.
Le soir, souvent,
c'est une soupe,
et après, une forme
de protéine végétale variée.
-Donc vous allez choisir
vos légumes ?
-Je mange aussi
des oeufs, du fromage,
des produits laitiers,
ce qui permet d'avoir
des protéines.
-Pourquoi vous avez conservé
les laitages et les oeufs ?
-Il y a un côté culturel.
C'est un des goûts
que j'aime le plus,
le goût du fromage,
et la diversité
de fromages qu'on a.
C'est vraiment le goût.
-La culture intensive,
ça vous évoque quoi ?
Souvent, on se dit
qu'il faut pouvoir nourrir
toute la planète.
Mais vous disiez
qu'il faut du local,
qu'on aille chercher les produits
à côté de chez soi.
-Ce dont on se rend pas compte,
c'est que ce qui pèse le plus
en termes d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
ou d'utilisation des terres,
c'est pas la distance du transport.
Le transport,
c'est une petite partie.
Le transport par cargos
est assez efficace.
Ce qui pèse le plus
sur les émissions de gaz,
c'est ce qu'on mange.
Mais le transport,
par exemple,
frigorifié, a une empreinte
carbone importante,
plus que le reste.
Du coup, il y a cet intérêt
à favoriser
ce qui est produit localement.
Et on a des meilleures
qualités nutritives
quand on achète des légumes
qui ont pas été
stockés pendant longtemps.
-Vous, par exemple, la banane,
la mangue, tous ces fruits,
ces légumes
qui pourraient
être importés de loin,
vous n'en mangez jamais ?
-Si, j'en mange, mais comme
quelque chose de plus rare,
et par bateau, pas par avion.
Parce que le transport par avion,
qui se fait pour des ananas,
par exemple, c'est l'empreinte
carbone la plus forte
par rapport au kilo de marchandise.
-Si ça vient par bateau,
c'est affiché ?
-Oui, et ça se voit dans le prix.
Je voulais mentionner
que je fais aussi partie
du Haut conseil pour le climat,
qui regarde plus les enjeux
dans le contexte français
de l'adaptation
à un climat qui change.
C'est un enjeu pour le système
alimentaire, de le rendre résilient.
Donc on travaille sur un rapport
sur l'agriculture et l'alimentation
qui sera publié
dans quelques semaines.
Ca montre l'ampleur des enjeux.
Et donc,
pour l'utilisation des terres,
dans son ensemble,
on est sur des défis majeurs.
D'une part, on a une population
à nourrir qui va augmenter.
On estime 2 milliards
de personnes
en plus à nourrir
dans les décennies qui viennent.
On a des chocs
sur les rendements agricoles
liés aux inondations,
aux pluies extrêmes,
aux chaleurs extrêmes
ou aux sécheresses
qui s'intensifient
par nos rejets de gaz
à effet de serre.
On a besoin aussi
de produire de la biomasse,
pour l'énergie, comme matériaux,
- c'est compliqué -
pour gérer l'utilisation
des terres.
Et c'est pour ça qu'en fait,
l'approche importante,
c'est pas seulement l'approche
production agricole,
- c'est important,
avec des gains possibles
sur les meilleures pratiques,
l'action contre la perte
et le gaspillage -
mais il y a aussi
ce qu'on choisit de manger.
Si ça n'avance pas
ensemble, ça fonctionnera pas.
Les pays autour de nous,
il y a 10 % de végétariens,
Suisse, Allemagne,
Royaume-Uni...
-En France, 2 %.
-On est en retard.
-Si par exemple
les gens mangent moins de viande
et qu'on en produit toujours autant,
ce sera exporté.
Ca ne changera rien.
En fait, on voit bien
que les deux aspects
ont besoin
d'avancer ensemble.
On est sur des situations
très compliquées.
Par exemple, les Français mangent
un peu moins de viande,
mais ça reste élevé.
-On en reparlera
plus tard, oui.
-Plus de poulet
que de viande rouge
et la moitié
des poulets est importée,
donc ce n'est pas correct non plus
en termes de filières agricoles.
-Vous aimez ce plat,
mais quand vous voulez
vous faire plaisir, aller
dans un restaurant gastronomique,
qu'est-ce qui
vous fait kiffer ?
-Je vais rarement
dans des restaurants gastronomiques,
pour être honnête.
C'est plutôt...
J'habite en Essonne,
à 25 km de Paris.
Il n'y a pas trop
d'offres gastronomiques.
C'est plus des brasseries.
-Il y a des étoilés
en campagne
et on y trouve des bons restaurants.
-Je ne crois pas
être déjà allée dans un restaurant
plusieurs étoiles, en fait.
Je fais aussi
de la recherche publique,
en fait.
-Vous ne voyez pas d'intérêt,
de plaisir
dans la nourriture ?
Vous vous contentez de...
-Je pense que dans ma famille,
on a une approche plus sobre
du budget
consacré à l'alimentation.
-Et la brasserie,
est-ce qu'elle s'est adaptée ?
En général,
il n'y avait pas,
en brasserie,
de plats végétariens.
-Si, il y a toujours.
-C'est un peu toujours
les mêmes plats qu'on trouve ?
-On voit plutôt
une approche
"cuisine du monde".
On va avoir des bols
un peu type asiatique,
variés, très jolis.
-A base de riz.
-Voilà, avec des fèves
à base de soja,
des choses comme ça.
On va avoir toute la cuisine
méditerranéenne,
qui a toujours
des choix végétariens,
cuisine asiatique aussi,
par tradition,
cuisine indienne aussi.
C'est plutôt là qu'on va trouver,
dans ma famille,
avec des choix
alimentaires contrastés,
ce qui convient
à tout le monde.
-Vous disiez :
"Notre famille consacre moins
"à l'alimentation
"une part de son revenu",
aujourd'hui...
-Je veux dire
à la restauration
haut de gamme.
C'est dans mes pratiques.
-Pas à l'alimentation
générale ?
Parce que, si on prend
du bio, du local,
c'est parfois un peu plus cher
que si on va acheter
des produits de grande consommation
dans les supermarchés.
-Par exemple, nous,
en Essonne, sur les marchés,
on a des producteurs
qui vendent directement.
On a aussi
des potagers d'insertion
près de chez nous.
Ce sont des personnes
qui sont éloignées
de l'emploi,
en situation précaire,
qui sont employées
dans ces potagers
et qui vendent directement.
Ca permet d'avoir
un coût abordable et surtout
des légumes délicieux.
-Vous trouvez
des produits bio abordables
ou il y a quand même
quelques introns ?
-Oui, on peut trouver
des potagers d'insertion bios,
par exemple,
qui font un travail
de qualité
sur les légumes fournis
et qui permettent à des gens
de retrouver l'emploi,
mais c'est pas le plus facile
en Ile-de-France.
-Vos filles ne vont jamais
dans les fast-foods ?
-Je ne peux pas
parler pour elles,
elles sont adultes.
-Mais plus jeunes ?
-Si, bien sûr.
Oui, oui.
Il y a une pression très forte
de la société à valoriser,
y compris avec les petits cadeaux,
une alimentation
qui n'est pas
le meilleur exemple
pour la santé.
-C'était une bataille ?
-Il y a eu différentes phases,
comme dans toutes les familles,
mais mes deux filles
cuisinent et voilà,
elles ont
une alimentation végétale.
-On va voir
si vous êtes vraiment incollable.
C'est le Quiz.
-Vous l'experte
en gaz à effet de serre
et en physique des fluides,
sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces faits
sur l'eau gazeuse,
donc carbonée,
sont vrais ou faux ?
-Je n'en ai aucune idée.
-Eh bien c'est vrai.
-Je vais dire oui.
-Ah pardon !
Ils rient.
J'ai bien senti
que ce oui était sincère,
donc on vous accorde le point.
-Et ce fameux Schweppe
donnera d'ailleurs le nom
de la marque Schweppes.
-Vrai ou faux ?
-Euh... On va dire vrai.
-Eh non : c'était
une consommation massive
et populaire d'eau gazéifiée,
ça faisait chic,
mais ça dépendait des marques.
Il y avait
de gros écarts de prix
entre les marques low cost, déjà,
et les marques aristocratiques,
mais c'était populaire
de boire de l'eau gazéifiée.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je ne sais pas du tout.
Je vais dire non.
-Non, c'était surtout
l'embouteillage
qui coûtait très cher.
Dernière affirmation.
-Ah, aucune idée. Je vais dire non.
-Eh non, vrai.
Ce sont des Anglais qui ont foré
à Perrier. C'est fou,
mais c'est des Anglais.
-Ce sont des Anglais.
Vous allez pouvoir vous rattraper
parce qu'il y a un deuxième quiz.
Vous qui êtes fan
de légumineuses,
savez-vous lesquelles sont utilisées
dans les différents potages
que je vais vous donner.
Alors, 1, le pois cassé.
Est-il utilisé dans le condé,
l'ésau, le saint-germain
ou le soissonnais ?
-Alors là,
c'est une très bonne question.
Soissonnais ?
-Saint-germain !
Ils rient.
Je ne pourrais pas
vous en dire plus.
2, le haricot rouge.
-Soissonnais ?
-Le condé !
-Deuxième tentative.
-Le condé.
Il nous reste deux...
-Je peux ajouter
une chose ? Les pois cassés,
délicieux en purée, en soupe.
Les haricots rouges, nous,
on a une recette
de substitut de steak
qu'on peut faire dans des burgers
à base de betteraves mixées,
de haricots rouges
et d'oignons caramélisés
qui est vraiment
délicieuse,
vraiment délicieuse.
-Elle a dit ça
pour faire diversion.
-C'est ça. 3.
On continue.
Vous n'allez pas
vous en sortir comme ça.
Le haricot blanc, est-ce que
c'est dans l'ésau ou...
-Le soissonnais !
-Le soissonnais.
Eh ben là, c'est bon.
On va y arriver.
-Les haricots de Soisson.
-Il y avait un bon indice.
-Finalement, le 4...
-Alors, les lentilles,
on se retrouve avec l'ésau.
Ca fait 50/50.
Vous avez quand même
deux bonnes réponses.
-C'est des soupes régionales.
-Voilà, c'est ça.
-Mais souvent, ces soupes
sont à base de légumineuses,
ce qui est
très intéressant.
-C'est autour de la table
que se racontent
les meilleures histoires,
que se nouent
des deals politiques,
que se font la petite
et la grande histoire.
La brève de comptoir.
Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
on vous a demandé
une anecdote,
pourquoi pas
autour d'un repas,
en politique. Vous avez
quelque chose à nous raconter ?
-Le mois dernier,
il y avait la préparation
du One Planet Summit
sur les pôles et les glaciers,
un sujet important parce que
ce qui se passe dans ces régions
affecte d'autres régions,
l'eau de fonte des glaciers
qui va alimenter les cours d'eau,
donc important pour l'irrigation,
l'agriculture,
ou bien la montée
du niveau de la mer,
un enjeu pour les littoraux,
et notamment le risque
de salinisation
des eaux côtières
ou les deltas agricoles,
au niveau mondial,
très exposés à cela,
et donc, dans ce dîner,
il y avait la ministre
de la Recherche, le ministre
de la Transition écologique,
des membres
du Conseil scientifique
qui préparaient ce sommet,
il y avait
Jean-Louis Etienne
et d'autres personnes,
et donc, la discussion
portait aussi
sur le financement,
bien sûr, qui a donné lieu
à des annonces du président
de la République
à ce sommet
et le ministre de la Transition
écologique regardait
le besoin de recherche pour évaluer
les risques d'instabilité
de certains secteurs
de l'Antarctique, c'est
le facteur d'incertitude
sur l'ampleur et la montée
du niveau de la mer qui peut
rajouter plusieurs dizaines
de centimètres
d'ici à la fin du siècle.
Il comparait le besoin
de financement
de la recherche sur l'Antarctique
à ne serait-ce que l'évaluation
de l'exposition
des communes du littoral,
c'est infime, ou bien
au coût
de la surélévation
de certaines digues, et donc,
la chose intéressante,
c'était se dire :
"On n'arrive pas à dégager
"un petit budget
pour cette recherche
"polaire, et pourtant,
les enjeux
"économiques sont considérables",
et donc, c'était le fait
de mettre en relation...
-Le delta
entre ces deux chiffres.
-Tout à fait.
-Et le montant,
ça correspond à combien ?
-A l'époque,
ce qui était discuté,
c'était un montant,
sur environ 10 ans,
de l'ordre de
50 millions d'euros
pour le financement
de la recherche
sachant que des investissements
ont été actés pour rénover
des bases Antarctique
ou changer de navire,
donc c'était juste la partie
financement de la recherche
à comparer aux milliards d'euros
déjà mis
pour évaluer l'exposition
des communes françaises
au risque de recul
du trait de côte
et au montant colossal
de chaque kilomètre
de digue à rehausser
ou de la relocalisation
qui devrait être planifiée
pour ceux qui sont
en première ligne.
-Avec ce qui est investi
dans la recherche,
on peut aussi faire
des économies, non ?
-Il y a plusieurs aspects, mais
on sait que tout ce qui est mis
sur la prévention des risques
est toujours efficace
par rapport
à la réparation
après catastrophe, donc ça,
c'est quelque chose de viable
et l'enjeu, c'est,
notamment parce que
le gouvernement veut
construire une trame
de référence
pour l'adaptation,
on voit qu'on peine
à réduire vite
les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Selon les politiques publiques,
le réchauffement
dans le monde serait
autour de 3 degrés
et si toutes les promesses
faites à horizon 2030
se réalisent, ce serait
entre 2,5 et 3 degrés.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Ca veut dire, en France,
4 degrés en fin de siècle.
En France, 3 degrés
en 2050.
Ca veut dire qu'en 2050,
ce qui était l'année la plus chaude
enregistrée à ce jour,
2022, avec son cortège
d'impacts graves...
-Maintenant, c'est l'année 2023.
-La plus chaude, c'est 2022.
2023 est juste derrière.
En France ! En France.
-Ah oui, pas dans le monde.
-Cette année-là, 2022,
vous vous souvenez,
la plus chaude,
ce serait l'année moyenne en 2050.
L'enjeu, c'est se préparer
à ce que sera l'année record de 2050
pour renforcer la résilience
pour l'eau,
la production alimentaire,
les infrastructures,
les endroits où on vit.
Et donc, voilà, investir
pour mieux caractériser
la réponse de l'Antarctique,
c'est aussi savoir
l'ampleur de la montée
du niveau de la mer,
et c'est pas pareil
si ça monte de 1 m
en 2300
ou si ça monte de 1 m
avant 2100, pour le littoral.
Donc, cette information,
elle est importante à avoir
pour avoir les meilleures réponses.
-Vous parlez de 2022,
de cette canicule.
Juste après,
le président de la République
vous a demandé
de vous exprimer
devant le gouvernement.
Je ne sais pas
si c'était autour du repas ?
-Non, c'était très formel.
C'était un séminaire
de rentrée gouvernementale,
dans une salle spectaculaire
de l'Elysée,
avec tous les ministres,
et moi, j'étais là au titre
de l'état des lieux scientifique,
Monde et France,
sur les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
dans le contexte
où la Première ministre
a mis en place
un aspect
de planification écologique
qui se décline graduellement,
sachant que ce double enjeu,
c'est comment faire face
à un climat qui se réchauffe
et après, d'autre part,
comment faire pour limiter
l'ampleur du réchauffement.
Ca va être très dur à gérer,
notamment dans tous les contextes
plus fragiles.
J'y pensais en écoutant
les personnes touchées
par les inondations dans le Nord.
Elles disaient : "On est coincés,
en zones inondables.
"Que va-t-on pouvoir faire
pour limiter le risque ?"
On est dans le dur.
-Sur quoi s'interrogeaient
les politiques, par exemple ?
-J'ai présenté l'état des lieux.
Ca a duré une vingtaine
ou une trentaine de minutes.
Après, j'ai écouté leurs échanges.
Un des points qui était frappant,
c'est un des ministres qui a dit...
Ils étaient en plein dedans.
Ils avaient géré crise après crise,
ils étaient vraiment bien concernés.
La question qui a été posée :
"On va avoir besoin
de changements structurels,
"et chaque fois
qu'on met en place
"ce type de changements,
"certains le comprennent,
et d'autres moins.
"Quel est le capital politique
à gagner ?"
Après, j'ai écouté...
-Il fallait un intérêt
pour eux !
-Leurs échanges sont instructifs.
Ce n'est pas mon monde.
Je suis dans un monde
de physicienne.
C'est instructif,
comme les enjeux d'articulation
et de mise en cohérence
de politiques publiques,
que j'ai appris
via le Haut conseil.
-Les scientifiques raillaient
les politiques.
Vous trouvez que ça a changé,
maintenant ?
Ils sont plus experts ?
-Il y a un enjeu
de monter en compétences.
D'abord, il y a un besoin,
toujours,
de formation continue,
sur l'état des connaissances
sur ces enjeux.
Certains se les sont appropriées,
mais pas tous.
Donc, il y a eu des actions
de formation,
notamment de cabinets ministériels,
de l'administration.
Ca, c'est extrêmement important.
Au-delà d'une sensibilisation,
c'est comment on porte
ces transformations,
quel est le retour d'expérience
d'autres pays,
soit des compétences
de conduite du changement
de science politique.
On voit bien
qu'il y a ce besoin.
Pour moi,
c'est une valeur des COP.
Elles sont souvent critiquées,
ces négociations,
mais c'est un espace
de dialogue
où on va avoir des coalitions
dans tel ou tel sujet.
Agriculture et alimentation,
c'est ressorti à Dubaï
plus fort qu'avant,
et d'autre part,
c'est là où il y a
des retours d'expérience
de ce qui fonctionne
qui peuvent être inspirants,
engageants.
-On va continuer
à parler de tout ça,
et on va s'intéresser à l'impact
de la viande sur la planète.
Qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière
un steak ou une côte de veau ?
C'est Le dessous des plats.
La production
et la consommation de viande
ont un impact important
sur le réchauffement climatique.
L'élevage serait responsable
de 14,5 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
La Cour des comptes préconise
de réduire le cheptel.
A les écouter,
les Français y sont prêts.
Reportage :
Perrouault et Le Gonidec.
-Les Français réduisent-ils
leur consommation de viande ?
Au marché de Malakoff,
en banlieue parisienne,
la réponse est plutôt oui.
Les consommateurs se veulent
de plus en plus responsables.
-Si on mange moins de viande,
ça devrait contribuer
à un meilleur climat,
moins d'énergie dépensée.
-Consommer trop de viande,
c'est éventuellement polluer.
En plus, pour la santé,
je pense qu'il est nécessaire
de réduire notre consommation.
-J'achète des produits
plus respectueux de la façon
dont on traite les animaux.
-Par rapport à la nature, oui,
on en mange beaucoup moins qu'avant.
Nos parents prenaient
beaucoup plus de viande que nous.
-Les dernières enquêtes d'opinion
sont claires :
les Français sont
de plus en plus nombreux
à déclarer consommer
moins de viande,
57 %,
selon une étude
Harris Interactive,
réalisée cette année.
Pourtant, cette tendance
ne se vérifie pas vraiment
dans les chiffres.
En 1998,
les Français consommaient
93,6 kilos de viande par an
en moyenne.
Ensuite, une baisse significative
s'est amorcée jusqu'en 2013,
mais depuis 10 ans, la consommation
repart en légère hausse.
A l'échelle mondiale,
l'évolution est plus nette.
La production globale de viande est
en constante augmentation
depuis les années 60,
et c'est surtout le cas en Asie.
43 % de la production mondiale
y est désormais concentrée,
principalement le porc
et la volaille.
L'Afrique est le continent
qui consomme le moins de viande,
mais un bond de 200 % est prévu
d'ici 2050.
Toutes ces évolutions
sont observées de près
par les organismes qui travaillent
sur le réchauffement climatique.
L'enjeu est majeur :
14,5 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre proviennent
aujourd'hui de l'élevage.
Ce qui pèse le plus,
c'est la production des aliments
pour nourrir le bétail.
Viennent ensuite
les fermentations entériques,
les rots des animaux
qui produisent du méthane,
puis le fumier
et l'énergie consommée,
notamment par le transport.
Les émissions dépendent aussi
des espèces.
La viande la plus émettrice,
c'est le boeuf.
En produire 1 kilo entraîne
38 kilos de CO2.
Viennent ensuite l'agneau,
le porc et le poulet.
Alors, Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
peut-on vraiment sauver la planète
en réduisant mondialement
la consommation de viande ?
-A vous !
-Alors, Valérie Masson-Delmotte ?
-Oui, faire évoluer l'éducation
à une alimentation saine et durable
sur, voilà,
une consommation responsable
de viande et laitage,
c'est un levier d'action.
-Une consommation responsable ?
En quelle quantité
faut-il réduire
sa consommation ?
-Alors, ça dépend
du point de départ.
Selon les personnes,
on a des pratiques
avec des consommations qui peuvent
être élevées ou raisonnables.
-Deux steaks par semaine ?
Est-ce que c'est de la viande
un jour sur deux ?
-L'idée, en fait...
-Et pas n'importe quelle viande !
Ca dépend de la viande.
-Si on regarde en France,
sur l'empreinte carbone,
par personne et par an,
à peu près 9 tonnes.
Le premier poste,
c'est les transports.
Le deuxième,
c'est l'alimentation,
avec la partie protéines animales
qui pèse plus que le reste,
puis la partie boisson,
parce que c'est lourd.
C'est le transport...
...plus loin
de choses plus lourdes.
Donc, si on regarde
les recommandations nutritionnelles,
on peut vivre très bien
en mangeant un ou deux steaks,
par exemple, par semaine,
quand on en mangeait davantage,
mais on n'est pas obligé
de le faire.
-Ca fait assez de protéines ?
-C'est intéressant,
il n'y a pas une réponse univoque,
il y a une multitude de choix,
et les personnes
avec des revenus plus élevés
réduisent leur consommation
de viande pour leur santé.
Par contre...
-Mais les pays
en voie de développement,
qui vont permettre
d'accéder à la viande,
vont consommer 200 % de plus !
-En fait, historiquement,
ça augmente avec les revenus,
la capacité à acheter de la viande.
-C'est un signe extérieur
de richesse aussi.
-C'est culturel.
Comment faire évoluer
notre regard sur ça
pour se dire, culturellement,
ce qu'on va valoriser
et on voit bien,
en France, dans les personnes
qui ont les revenus
les plus contraints,
il y a une aspiration
à consommer de la viande
comme un signe de pouvoir
nourrir sa famille
avec des protéines,
qu'on associe
à des valeurs de force.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on dit
à l'Afrique, qui va consommer,
c'est prévu,
beaucoup plus de viande
d'ici 2050 ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit ?
Ils ont envie d'accéder à la viande.
Ils n'en avaient pas.
Ils avaient pas
le pouvoir d'achat, avant.
On dit non ?
-Ce qui m'a frappée...
-Il faut même pas
commencer ?
-En 2019,
on avait porté un rapport du GIEC
sur le changement climatique
et l'utilisation des terres
dans la sécurité alimentaire,
et notamment en Afrique,
avec des scientifiques
du monde entier.
C'était un des rapports
les plus constructifs.
Ca montrait les options d'action
qui permettent à la fois
de répondre
à des enjeux d'adaptation
à un climat
qui se réchauffe,
de réduction d'émissions,
de préservation des écosystèmes
de la biodiversité,
car si on veut davantage
nourrir un cheptel d'animaux
important dans le monde,
on va déforester
pour avoir des espaces de culture.
-On pourrait imaginer...
-Ce qui était frappant,
c'est qu'il y a des contextes
où les gens dépendent vraiment,
notamment dans des zones
semi-arides,
des protéines animales
et c'est critique,
en fait,
pour leur sécurité alimentaire.
Il y a des contextes différents.
Il y a des traditions,
des pratiques...
Ce qui ressortait
des scientifiques africains,
un chercheur d'ailleurs
du Sénégal qui avait piloté
le chapitre
sur l'alimentation,
c'était aussi de valoriser
les connaissances locales,
culturelles,
sur une alimentation
saine et soutenable.
Le fait de consommer
plus de viande ne vient pas
spontanément
des populations locales.
C'est aussi construit
par les acteurs industriels.
Sur ce rapport,
et les autres du GIEC,
on avait souligné
les enjeux
de soutien
aux agriculteurs
pour qu'ils soient résilients,
pour que les meilleures pratiques
soient valorisées.
L'élevage sur herbe,
c'est une des meilleures options,
par exemple,
pour réduire
l'empreinte carbone
des ruminants
et des produits laitiers.
On a des savoir-faire
qu'il faut valoriser.
Ce qui ressortait,
c'était plutôt les grands pays
exportateurs de viande,
comme en Amérique du Sud,
qui eux-mêmes ont essayé
d'affaiblir la partie qui portait
sur le fait
de végétaliser
l'alimentation.
Il y avait pas d'obstruction
de pays africains.
-Comme le Brésil ?
-Brésil, Argentine.
Là, vraiment,
c'est plutôt l'industrie
de l'exportation de viande,
à très grande échelle,
qui cherche à conserver ses marchés,
ou à en créer un nouveau.
C'est pas juste
des aspirations
spontanées et locales.
C'est à regarder avec précaution.
Les sujets les plus sensibles
dans l'approbation des rapports
du GIEC,
c'était celui-là :
végétaliser la part des protéines,
en cas
de surconsommation
de protéines animales.
Le deuxième sujet sensible
portait sur la réduction
du recours à l'énergie fossile.
C'était d'autres acteurs :
les exportateurs
d'énergies fossiles.
-On pourrait imaginer
que les animaux mangent
une autre nourriture ?
Pas le soja qui oblige à déforester
une partie de l'Amazonie.
-De l'herbe
pour les ruminants.
-Mais l'herbe
en Afrique...
-Ca contribue aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
la nourriture des animaux.
-Bien sûr et...
Dans le reportage,
c'était assez marqué :
les gens ont l'impression
de consommer moins de viande,
mais avec les plats préparés,
les fast-foods,
il y a une tendance,
dans l'alimentation
plus industrielle,
facile d'accès,
à avoir une consommation
plus élevée de viande.
On est sur des choses
un peu contradictoires.
Il y a des effets liés à l'âge.
Souvent,
les personnes âgées
font plus attention
à leur santé et donc,
font évoluer leur alimentation,
la végétalisent
un peu plus,
et il y a parfois
une forme d'indifférence
chez les plus jeunes.
-Scénario de fiction :
on interdit la viande.
On sauve la planète ou pas ?
-Ca se pose pas en ces termes,
ni en France ni dans le monde.
C'est plutôt...
Pourquoi ? Je vais l'expliquer.
Le reportage tout à l'heure
reliait un kilo
de différents types de viande
à des émissions de CO2,
mais ça fonctionne pas ainsi.
Ce sont des émissions de méthane
et par les épandages,
d'oxyde nitreux,
deux autres gaz
à effet de serre.
Pour limiter le réchauffement,
il faudra être
à zéro émission de CO2.
C'est la première chose.
Ca, c'est surtout énergies fossiles
et déforestation.
Pour le méthane, il s'agit
de réduire, pas d'aller à zéro.
Il faut pas être caricatural.
-On peut donc manger
de la viande ?
-En valorisant
les filières
les plus vertueuses,
comme les ruminants sur herbe.
C'est aussi une viande
qui va être plus chère.
L'idée, c'est de valoriser
les bonnes pratiques,
comment les rendre
mieux visibles,
reconnaître les efforts
faits par les exploitants
qui les mettent en place.
C'est aussi un enjeu
sur les marchés internationaux.
On parlait tout à l'heure
de l'alimentation
industrielle.
Là, en fait,
les commerçants,
la grande distribution,
va chercher
la viande la moins chère
faite d'une façon
qui n'est pas
celle qu'on décrivait,
mais le consommateur
ne le voit pas.
Comment arriver
à le rendre plus visible ?
-Brigitte parlait
de changer
l'alimentation des animaux.
Il faudrait la transformer
pour baisser
les émissions de méthane,
la nourriture ?
-Il y a des enjeux
sur les pratiques d'alimentation,
sur certains compléments
alimentaires
qui peuvent permettre
de réduire
cet aspect-là.
C'est des petits leviers d'action
pas négligeables
à grande échelle.
C'est exploré actuellement.
-La viande
de synthèse,
ça peut être une solution
pour pallier, finalement,
ce...
-Ca peut être...
-...cette réduction
de viande traditionnelle ?
-C'est des choses un peu de niche.
Bien sûr, si on veut "brasser"
des cellules animales,
comme de la bière,
il y a une consommation
de matière première pour le faire,
d'énergie, donc voilà,
il faut bien regarder ce qu'on gagne
et ce qu'on évite.
Ceux qui favorisent ces approches
sont plutôt ceux qui ont
un attachement à éviter
la souffrance animale, notamment,
et qui seraient intéressés
par des alternatives
sans cette dimension-là.
Il y a quelques démonstrateurs
mais c'est pas, aujourd'hui,
à l'échelle nécessaire,
et c'est souvent associé
à un coût assez élevé.
-Et les insectes ?
-Dans plusieurs régions
du monde, les insectes sont
une source de protéines.
-La FAO veut mettre le paquet
sur les insectes.
-On en parle pour l'alimentation
des animaux d'élevage,
avec des protéines d'insectes,
pour une empreinte plus soutenable.
-Il y a des alternatives.
-Mais il y a des freins culturels
qui sont intéressants.
Les pratiques alimentaires,
on voit que c'est ancré
dans des cultures. En France,
c'est acceptable de manger
des cuisses de grenouilles.
Ailleurs, pas du tout.
Après, ça demande à regarder :
par exemple,
les cuisses de grenouilles
qui sont importées de pays
où on a une chute de la diversité
de batraciens, comme en Indonésie,
on est sur des choses pas du tout
durables, il y a un décalage
entre le ressenti des gens
et la réalité des filières
d'approvisionnement.
C'est pour ça,
les insectes ou autres,
dans certaines régions du monde,
c'est perçu comme une chance,
quelque chose
qui est associé parfois
à des fêtes,
des moments dans les saisons,
donc ça demande aussi
de s'interroger sur le regard
qu'on porte sur différentes
sources de protéines.
-En plus d'émettre
beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre,
l'agriculture est le secteur
le plus consommateur d'eau.
L'eau, une denrée
de plus en plus rare
avec le réchauffement climatique,
on en parle.
-Avec la sécheresse,
une source s'est tarie
dans le département de l'Aude.
Résultat,
deux petits villages
au régime sec.
Au robinet, l'eau qui coule
provient de camions-citernes.
Pas de pluie dans les champs
pour les cultures, le quotidien est
à réinventer
pour les habitants.
C'est un reportage
de Clément Perrouault.
Musique intrigante
-La sécheresse
au mois de décembre.
Coustouge, dans le massif
des Corbières, affronte
une pénurie d'eau.
Pour y remédier,
voilà le traitement :
des camions-citernes
viennent alimenter
le village deux fois par semaine.
L'eau vient
de Lézignan,
à 25 kilomètres d'ici.
-Il y a 29 000 litres, là.
Ca tient à peu près
deux jours sur la commune.
-L'eau est versée dans le réseau
communal de Coustouge
et de Jonquières,
le village voisin.
Les deux communes
rassemblent 200 habitants
au total.
Leurs maires sont venus
tous les deux
assister aux opérations.
La situation les inquiète beaucoup.
-On ne contrôle rien,
on est tributaires
des précipitations.
Les prévisions météo
sont très
défavorables.
-On parle souvent
d'un dérèglement climatique,
on est en plein dedans.
On a un manque crucial
de précipitations
ces deux dernières années.
Voilà à quoi ça aboutit :
une pénurie d'eau
et ce ravitaillement par citerne.
-Depuis plusieurs années,
les deux villages étaient
alimentés par cette source
mais elle s'est définitivement
tarie fin novembre, faute
de précipitations.
-C'est sec.
C'est inédit,
on l'a jamais vue
asséchée à ce point.
Ca coule toujours un peu
mais là, on n'a
plus rien du tout.
-Dans ces conditions,
au village, les habitants
ont appris à limiter
leur consommation
d'eau,
chacun à sa manière.
-On a mis des économiseurs d'eau
à chaque robinet.
-Sous la douche,
on met moins de temps.
Les chasses d'eau,
on économise.
-La vaisselle, au lieu
de la faire systématiquement,
je la fais le matin.
Je stocke la vaisselle.
-La pénurie d'eau n'affecte pas
que le quotidien des particuliers.
Conjuguée à la chaleur, elle est
une calamité pour les viticulteurs,
comme Valérie Segonne.
Sa vigne est en situation
de stress hydrique.
-Là, on a de la repousse.
La vigne repousse alors
qu'on est au mois de décembre.
-La vigne est déréglée,
elle ne sait pas
qu'on est en décembre.
Elle s'apprête à pousser,
alors que c'est en mars-avril
qu'elle pousse.
Elle se croit au printemps.
-Le bois des vignes
est aussi beaucoup plus faible.
Cette année,
sur cette parcelle,
la production de vin
a chuté de 60 %.
-Alors, alimenter un village
de 200 habitants
et des camions-citernes,
ça va,
mais si dans l'avenir,
ce sont des villes entières
de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'habitants,
comment va-t-on faire ?
-On voit les enjeux majeurs
liés au réchauffement planétaire,
où à mesure de l'ampleur
du réchauffement,
dans certaines régions,
c'est une baisse
de la pluviométrie
qui va aggraver l'occurrence,
l'intensité des sécheresses.
C'est le cas cette année
en Amazonie, par exemple.
Ca a été le cas en France,
en 2022, sécheresses records.
Encore maintenant...
-L'Espagne aussi.
-Oui, sur la partie
méditerranéenne.
-Ca veut dire quoi ?
Il y aura
des camions-citernes
qui iront dans les villes
pour alimenter en eau ?
-A la Nouvelle Orléans,
il y a une entrée d'eau salée,
ça fait que l'alimentation
en eau potable est compliquée
parce que l'eau
devient de plus en plus saline,
impropre à la consommation.
Mayotte, plus d'eau potable.
-On livre des millions
de bouteilles !
-Cette échelle interroge
sur les petites îles
qui n'ont pas de stock
d'une plus grande vulnérabilité,
et les déchets aussi.
Que fait-on avec ces bouteilles
plastique ? Catastrophique
pour la vie au quotidien.
On voit que, dans un climat
qui se réchauffe,
on a un cycle de l'eau
plus intense
et plus variable,
plus de saisons
et d'événements humides et secs.
Parfois, c'est l'excès
et parfois, la pénurie.
En Méditerranée,
c'est les points chauds
d'un climat qui se réchauffe.
On a moins de précipitations
et quand il fait chaud,
on vide plus vite
les sols de leur humidité.
Il y a les deux facteurs.
-Quand il y a trop d'eau,
les nappes phréatiques
remontent pas.
-Ca va dépendre.
Il y a l'effet surface
et il y a le temps
de réponse des nappes
avec parfois leur utilisation locale
qui est pas du tout
soutenable.
On prélève plus d'eau
que ce qui se renouvelle.
Le niveau des nappes baisse,
comme en Espagne.
On est sur des enjeux
d'aridification.
Ce qui me frappe,
dans les conflits récents,
c'est à quel point
l'eau est une arme de guerre
et un facteur de conflit.
Entre l'Ukraine et la Russie,
il y a une utilisation
non durable de l'eau,
à l'est de l'Ukraine,
et l'eau a été utilisée
dans les deux cas
comme une arme de guerre.
Entre Israël et Palestine,
pareil, contexte méditerranéen,
une ressource très contrainte,
y compris un appauvrissement
des nappes,
et une population
qui augmente.
On est sur des tensions
très lourdes.
-Il faut trouver des alternatives.
En France, notamment,
le traitement d'eaux usées,
la dessalinisation,
est-ce que ce sont
des alternatives ?
-On a regardé ça dans un rapport
de l'Académie des technologies,
sur comment rajouter
des ressources en eau,
qui étaient pas
exploitées précédemment.
Il y a un potentiel
très limité.
La dessalinisation
consomme beaucoup.
Donc, très restreint
à des contextes spécifiques,
comme les îles.
-On rejette
le sel. L'eau est
encore plus salée.
C'est ça ?
-Il y a des enjeux
le moins mal possible,
quand on le fait.
-Sur le papier, c'est...
On dirait une bonne solution.
-Ca consomme
beaucoup d'énergie.
La deuxième chose,
réutiliser des eaux usées,
dans certains contextes,
c'est faisable.
Ce sont des enjeux
d'assurer la qualité
de ces eaux
par rapport à leurs usages.
-Israël le fait très bien,
par exemple,
pour presque 90 % de son eau.
Il y a un moyen d'avoir
cette alternative.
-Oui.
Mais ça augmente pas
la ressource.
En France, on s'attend,
à mesure du réchauffement, à avoir
une hausse des vagues de chaleur,
une baisse de l'humidité
des sols graduelle.
Ce qu'on voit,
c'est une double contrainte.
On aura besoin de plus d'eau,
pour l'irrigation
et garder nos cultures.
D'autre part,
on aura une ressource
qui risque de diminuer
et elle diminue aussi
par l'enneigement réduit,
on a un recul
des glaciers aussi.
La capacité
à déstocker de l'eau,
quand on en a le plus besoin
se réduit aussi depuis la montagne.
La réponse n'est pas seulement
dans les technologies
qui vont permettre
d'utiliser mieux l'eau,
c'est aussi ce qui était décrit
par les habitants du village :
ce qu'on peut faire
au quotidien...
-C'est le système D.
-C'est être plus efficace
à l'échelle individuelle aussi.
-Des douches moins longues,
pas tirer la chasse à chaque fois,
économiser
pendant la vaisselle.
-Ca, c'est l'échelle individuelle.
Après on a la qualité...
-C'est efficace,
ces gestes du quotidien ?
-C'est une partie
de la réponse.
Il y a le réseau qui fuit.
L'entretien,
c'est un point important.
La qualité des réseaux.
Ce qui prélève
le plus d'eau,
notamment en été,
c'est l'irrigation.
Donc avoir des techniques
performantes
de micro-irrigation,
qui vont permettre
d'assurer la sécurité alimentaire,
c'est important,
en limitant
l'utilisation de l'eau.
-On entend que "sobriété".
Est-ce que c'est
une politique publique ?
-C'est plutôt une approche
vraiment intelligente.
On est surtout
en situations de gaspillage,
souvent. C'est plutôt
être le plus intelligent
collectivement
sur ce qui peut être fait.
Il y a des exemples
dans plein de pays différents,
qui montrent
ce qui peut être fait,
et aussi les limites dures.
On utilise ce terme
par rapport à l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques.
On est dos au mur.
Pas d'eau dans un cours d'eau,
c'est une limite dure.
Là, on voit bien
qu'on va passer
en gestion de crise,
et pas en résilience.
-Une douche courte,
c'est le bon sens.
On a déjà réglementé
l'usage de l'eau
dans les cultures.
Est-ce qu'un jour,
on va réglementer
dans les maisons ?
Ca, vous le voyez venir ?
-Il y a des réflexions
sur les besoins de base
et la tarification.
Par exemple,
pour les besoins de base,
avoir un tarif faible.
Et puis, au contraire,
augmenter quand on a
une utilisation excessive.
-Ca gonfle la facture
et ça limite les gens.
Mais réglementer l'usage ?
-C'est une atteinte
aux libertés.
-Mais quand on vous entend...
-J'ai jamais entendu parler
de réflexions dans ce sens.
Dans les communes touchées
par des restrictions très dures,
on voit que les gens prennent
la mesure des enjeux et se partagent
les meilleures pratiques.
-Aujourd'hui,
mais en entendant votre exposé,
on se dit :
et dans 30 ans ?
On nous dira :
vous avez le droit
à 5 l aujourd'hui.
-Ca, c'est ce qu'il y a
à Mayotte.
-Bah, alors, voilà.
-Et c'est atroce, en fait.
Vous imaginez la vie...
-Est-ce que Mayotte
préfigure ce qui peut
se passer ?
-J'ai vu à Singapour,
où ils sont très contraints...
Ils rachètent l'eau usée
de la Malaisie,
la traite et la distribuent
à la ville,
qui a peu de ressources.
C'était plutôt
de l'encouragement.
Par exemple,
dans les douches,
une couleur qui passe
du vert au bleu,
au bout de quelques minutes.
Ca donne un signal.
C'est pas une obligation.
Mais c'est un signal...
-Un rappel
à l'ordre.
-"Là, c'est du luxe,
"vous avez déjà utilisé..."
C'est plutôt ces approches
incitatives, le bon sens,
se prendre en main
collectivement,
quand on est dans une crise,
qui fonctionnent le mieux.
-Il y a la COP28
en ce moment à Dubaï,
quelles sont les décisions
à prendre
pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique
à 1,5 ou 2 degrés,
ce qui était l'accord de Paris ?
-Ce qu'on voit,
c'est que le premier facteur
du réchauffement
actuel et futur,
c'est le cumul
des émissions de CO2,
qu'on émet
quand on brûle du charbon,
du pétrole, du gaz,
ou quand on détruit
une forêt.
Et la marge de manoeuvre
pour limiter le réchauffement
à 1,5 degré,
année après année,
elle se réduit.
On estime qu'au rythme actuel
des émissions,
parce que ça continue
à monter,
moins vite qu'avant,
on aura épuisé cette marge
qui nous reste
pour contenir
le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
avant la fin de cette décennie.
On va vers ce niveau
de réchauffement,
ça va être compliqué, ça va demander
plus d'efforts d'adaptation,
plus d'efforts
pour accompagner
les plus fragiles,
comme les mécanismes
de pertes et dommages.
Donc, le point clé,
si on veut être sérieux,
arriver à limiter
le réchauffement
à ce niveau, pour éviter
des choses ingérables
- l'eau,
la sécurité alimentaire -,
c'est planifier
collectivement une sortie
des énergies fossiles.
-Toutes ?
-Une sortie graduelle
des énergies fossiles,
en commençant
par le charbon.
-Là, Emmanuel Macron a fixé 2030,
comme objectif.
-En France.
-Non, 2027 en France.
Et 2030 pour tout le monde.
-C'est un appel.
C'est un appel.
-Le charbon...
-Les Chinois...
-...Pétrole, puis gaz.
C'est très important.
-Le tout, à quelle échéance ?
-Graduel, et à horizon 2050.
Si on veut vraiment limiter
le réchauffement, il faut
que les émissions mondiales de CO2
liées aux activités
humaines soient à 0.
Si on en émet encore
dans des secteurs difficiles,
il faut être capable d'en éliminer,
et on n'y est pas.
Dans ce contexte-là,
chaque mot compte.
On voit bien qu'on est
dans le dur,
pendant la COP28
où cette question est
sur le devant de la table.
C'est une COP présidée
par le PDG de la compagnie
nationale émiratie
dans un pays qui... voilà,
est un exportateur de gaz
et de pétrole,
comme beaucoup
dans cette région.
Un pays qui aborde
plus frontalement les enjeux
de diversification économique
que ses voisins,
et notamment l'Arabie saoudite,
qui a pris des positions
très dures,
ne souhaitant pas
qu'on mentionne
le fait de sortir
des énergies fossiles
ou même ces termes.
-Vous avez un doute
sur la réussite de la COP.
-Non, on est dans le dur.
Il faut le comprendre.
J'ai vu, notamment dans des rapports
d'évaluation scientifique
comme ceux du GIEC,
le poids des pays exportateurs
d'énergies fossiles,
l'Arabie saoudite ou la Russie,
pour essayer d'atténuer
les conclusions
et servir leurs intérêts.
Ils disent
que l'enjeu n'est pas
de sortir
des énergies fossiles,
mais de réduire
les émissions
en faisant miroiter
une capacité d'arriver
à utiliser des énergies fossiles
en captant les émissions de CO2
et en les stockant.
C'est pour ça que le Haut Conseil
pour le climat
a rendu un avis sur cet aspect-là,
avant la COP,
la semaine dernière,
à la demande
de la Première ministre,
pour évaluer
le potentiel réel.
Il faut comprendre
que les compagnies
de pétrole savent bien
transporter du liquide et du gaz
et le stocker ou le déstocker
de réservoirs géologiques.
Dans leur vision, après avoir été
payées pour en extraire,
être payées pour le capter
et le stocker,
c'est une opportunité,
mais le potentiel est limité.
Le coût est élevé.
Ca ne se déploie pas
à l'échelle. L'enjeu,
c'est progresser
sur l'efficacité énergétique,
les renouvelables,
le nucléaire,
si on le souhaite. Ca fait partie
des annonces en début de COP.
On est dans le dur.
Ce n'est pas qu'ajouter
du renouvelable...
-On espère qu'il y aura une décision
dans le bon sens qui sera prise.
On va passer maintenant au dessert
et c'est Le péché mignon.
-Alors, après les légumes
de saison,
on suit la logique,
on a des fruits de saison.
C'est ce qu'a demandé,
Mme Masson-Delmotte.
Dans ce dessert, on a des fruits
de saison, mais pas de chez nous.
Vous nous direz
si ça convient.
En tout cas, la sobriété,
les fruits
et les légumes de saison,
c'est un peu votre mantra.
On s'attendait
à une pâtisserie.
Mais non, rien !
-Je dois expliquer
que j'ai eu un rhume carabiné
la semaine dernière.
On a besoin
de vitamines.
-Sinon, c'était mousse
au chocolat.
-Vous, vous êtes plutôt
fruits que desserts
ou pâtisseries ?
-Non, non.
J'aime bien aussi
le sucré, raisonnablement.
Un de mes desserts préférés,
c'est le clafoutis aux cerises.
-Vous savez le faire ?
-C'est pas la saison.
Mais oui, bien sûr.
Oui, oui.
C'est de la pâte à crêpes
et des cerises.
-Oui. C'est assez bon.
On finit toujours l'émission
en chanson.
Vous avez choisi celle-là.
*"2083", Grand Corps Malade
*-Cher Fabien
Tu ne me connais pas encore
Je suis ton petit-fils
Je t'écris depuis l'année 2083
Je te passe ce message
Afin que ton époque réagisse
Ici la planète va mal
Il faut absolument que tu me croies
Djakarta Lagos New York
Ont disparu sous la mer
Mais aussi Venise Londres
Et un tiers des Pays-Bas
Tombouctou et le nord Mali
Ensevelis sous le désert
Et le fleuve Niger n'a plus
Une seule goutte d'eau dans ses bras
Les villes côtières qui luttent
Contre la montée des eaux
Ont beau construire des digues
Des barrages et des murailles
Elles ne pèsent pas bien lourd
Et éclatent vite en morceaux
Quand les cyclones et ouragans
Viennent finir le travail
Dans plusieurs pays d'Afrique
Et d'Asie du Sud-Est
Mais aussi à Athènes au Caire
Et quelques autres élues
Il fait souvent 60 degrés
Chaque été est un test
Où les riches vivent sous la clim
Et les pauvres ne vivent plus
-Alors, c'est "2083",
de Grand Corps Malade.
On a compris le message
écologique et politique.
-C'est une chanson
où il fait parler son petit-fils,
en 2083, avec lui.
Il fait une référence
au fait d'ignorer
les rapports du GIEC.
J'aime bien qu'il se projette,
se dire :
où on sera à ce moment-là ?
Comment on vivra ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fera ?
Quel futur ne veut-on pas vivre ?
Où est-ce qu'on veut être ?
Comment on va y arriver ?
Le côté positif,
qui est pas abordé là.
-Grand Corps Malade. Merci.
-On devrait passer la chanson
au début de chaque COP.
-En début de COP.
Ca peut être une idée.
-Dans toutes les langues.
-Merci,
Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
d'être venue.
Merci
à Chez Françoise
qui nous a fourni
ces plats délicieux.
Merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis.
On se voit la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
*...
*-Cher petit-fils
J'ai lu ton courrier avec effroi